did you you know how rare it is for
Walmart to close doors you know how rare
it is for Walmart to close a store okay
Walmart and one of their blue cities
that they're in okay okay here we go on
Thursday company spokesperson come from
two locations in Portland Oregon I
wonder why they're going in there taking
products leaving you can't do about
it yeah Portland Walmart closures
attract national attention Wheeler Texas
governor Albert spars with uh and and
the way they put it's like well you know
they're having a hard time but look at
the story Walmart last month announced
it's closing two of its Portland stores
but it's drawn a fresh round of
attention this week as politicians part
uh online over the cause the detail
giant will lay off 580 employees when
the stores close March 24th according to
a regular tourism course here are five
things to know about the closures whose
article is this by the way there's no
single live.com oregonlive.com so why is
Walmart closing some are saying it's
because Walmart's not having a lot of
business some are saying because they're
being robbed and they're like there's no
profit yeah so why is he getting so much
attention they're going back and for
Golden Lord to see the data on this one
here go a little lower so you see Texas
governor Abbott who took aim at Portland
over the issue saying the closure is
what happens when cities refuse to
enforce the rule of law exactly Portland
Oregon out of all the cities like it's
not like it's Dallas Texas yeah and
Walmart rarely ever closes stores I've
never seen for Walmart to say we quit
that says a lot about your city whoever
the mayor of Portland is when you lose
Walmart that's like when you were to
coach when LeBron or Michael or Kobe
says I'm leaving your team how the hell
do you lose Walmart
how do you lose it's like the 600 jobs
for your guys in your city that's the
were they the same as uh New York and
Cali where it's like under a thousand
bucks you just they don't give a
they're not gonna they're not even it's
not sorry California is lowering it from
a thousand I believe Portland OR
California is lowering it from a
thousand to 450 to minimize perfect but
to Walmart how many people leave with
450. yeah I don't share your thing
exactly TV exactly that's the what is
the number it's a yeah they lowered it
from a thousand dollars to 450. so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]